NATION'S HIGHEST COURT.
CNN CONGRESSIONAL REPORTER
DANIELLA DIAZ JOINS US NOW.
GOOD MORNING.
GIVE US A BIT OF INSIGHT.
HOW HAS JUDGE JACKSON BEEN
PREPARING FOR THESE HEARINGS?
>> Reporter: SOURCES TELL US
SHE'S BEEN PREPARING JUST LIKE
PREVIOUS SUPREME COURT NOMINEES
BEFORE HER BY PARTICIPATING AND
PREPARING HERSELF FOR THE
QUESTIONS SHE'LL LIKELY RECEIVE
FROM REPUBLICANS WHEN SHE GOES
INTO THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
THIS WEEK.
IT'S JUST AS YOU SAID, SHE IS
MAKING HISTORY AS THE FIRST
SUPREME COURT NOMINEE, THE FIRST
BLACK WOMAN TO BE NOMINATED TO
THE SUPREME COURT.
BUT THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE THE
FIRST TIME SHE'S FACED CONGRESS.
SHE'S ACTUALLY FACED CONGRESS
THREE TIMES BEFORE THIS FOR
SEVERAL JOBS, INCLUDING THE U.S.
SENTENCING COMMISSION, THE DC
DISTRICT COURT, AND THE DC
CIRCUIT COURT OF APPEALS.
WE EXPECT REPUBLICANS TO GO
TOUGH ON HER FOR ALLEGATIONS
THEY'VE BEEN FLOATING THAT SHE
HAS BEEN SOFT ON CRIME, AND THE
REPUBLICAN STRATEGY IS EXPECTED
TO BE TWOFOLD.
QUESTIONS ABOUT JACKSON'S
EXPERIENCE AS A JUDGE, PUBLIC
DEFENDER, TIME SPENT ON A
FEDERAL COMMISSION THAT
ULTIMATELY SLASHED DRUG
SENTENCES AND THEY ALSO PLAN TO
PIVOT TO QUESTIONING HER ON THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION POLICIES.
BUT I DO WANT TO NOTE MOST
RECENTLY SHE FACED CONGRESS AND
WAS CONFIRMED TO THE DC
DISTRICT -- EXCUSE ME, THE DC
CIRCUIT COURT OF APPEALS IN
2021, AND SHE ACTUALLY WON THE
SUPPORT FROM THREE REPUBLICANS.
THOSE REPUBLICANS BEING SENATORS
SUSAN COLLINS, LINDSEY GRAHAM
AND LISA MURKOWSKI, AND EVEN
SENATE MINORITY LEADER MITCH
MCCONNELL ACKNOWLEDGED THIS WEEK
IN AN INTERVIEW SHE'S LIKELY
GOING TO BE CONFIRMED BY
DEMOCRATIC SUPPORT, BUT HE DID
SAY LIKELY FEW REPUBLICAN VOTES.
TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT HE SAID
THURSDAY MORNING IN A RADIO
INTERVIEW.
>> I THINK JUDGE JACKSON WILL BE
TREATED RESPECTFULLY, I THINK
THE QUESTIONS WILL BE
APPROPRIATE, AND I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT, I THINK SHE'S HIGHLY
LIKELY TO BE CONFIRMED WITH VERY
FEW REPUBLICAN VOTES, BECAUSE OF
HER PHILOSOPHY, NOT ANYTHING
ELSE.
>> Reporter: KRISTIN, BORIS, IF
KETANJI BROWN JACKSON IS
CONFIRMED TO THE SUPREME COURT,
SHE WILL ACTUALLY FOLLOW IN THE
FOOTSTEPS OF PREVIOUS SUPREME
COURT NOMINEES, NOW JUDGES,
KNEEL GORSUCH, JOHN ROBERTS, BY
REPLACING HER FORMER BOSS ON THE
BENCH, BEING, OF COURSE, STEPHEN
BREYER, AND WE DO EXPECT THIS
WEEK TO BE INCREDIBLY BUSY ON
CAPITOL HILL AS THESE
CONFIRMATIONS BEGIN TOMORROW AT
11:00 A.M. EASTERN.
BORIS, KRISTIN.
>> DANIELLA DIAZ LIVE FROM
CAPITOL HILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>>> LET'S GET ANALYSIS NOW FROM
THE DEAN OF BOSTON UNIVERSITY'S
LAW SCHOOL.
SHE PENNED A LETTER LAST MONTH
THAT HUNDREDS OF OTHER LAW DEANS
HAVE SIGNED ONTO, CALLING FOR
JUDGE JACKSON TO BE CONFIRMED
QUICKLY.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING WITH US.
JUST RIGHT OFF THE BAT, WHAT
CONCERNS YOU MIGHT SLOW DOWN HER
CONFIRMATION?
>> WHAT CONCERNS MIGHT SLOW DOWN
HER CONFIRMATION, I THINK THE
QUESTIONS ABOUT HER SENTENCING
ON CASES INVOLVING
NON-PRODUCTION CHILD
PORNOGRAPHY.
SENATOR JOSH HOWLEY HAS SAID
THAT HE PLANS TO ASK HER
QUESTIONS ABOUT THESE SENTENCES,
HE PLANS TO ASK HER QUESTIONS
ABOUT HER WORK ON THE
COMMISSION, AND I THINK THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS MIGHT SLOW IT
DOWN.
I AGREE WITH SENATOR McCONNELL,
SHE'LL GET CONFIRMED, BUT I
DON'T THINK THAT IT WILL SLOW IT
DOWN.
BUT I THINK THAT IT WILL BE PART
OF THE SHOW OF THE CONFIRMATION
HEARINGS.
>> YOU KNOW, REPUBLICANS ARE
ALREADY, OF COURSE, EXPECTEDLY
PREPARING THEIR ATTACKS AGAINST
THE JUDGE, AND, YOU KNOW,
NOTABLY IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT
SENATOR JOSH HOWLEY HAS
SUGGESTED, SAYING ESSENTIALLY
THAT SHE'S OVERLY SYMPATHETIC TO
SEX OFFENDERS IN RULINGS, OUR
TEAM LOOKED AT THAT AND REVIEWED
WHAT HE WAS SAYING AND IT SHOWED
THAT SHE MOSTLY FOLLOWED THE
JUDICIAL PATH AND HE SEEMED TO
HAVE TAKEN SOME OF HER COMMENTS
OUT OF CONTEXT.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS GOING TO
PRESENT A REAL CHALLENGE TO HER
NOMINATION?
>> I DON'T THINK IT WILL PRESENT
A REAL CHALLENGE TO HER
NOMINATION.
HER SENTENCES WILL COMPLETELY IN
THE MAINSTREAM, ACTUALLY 30% OF
CHOOILD PORNOGRAPHY CASES GET A
SENTENCE IN THE GUIDELINES.
70% OF JUDGES AGREE THE
SENTENCING GUIDELINES ON THOSE
PARTICULAR TYPES OF CASES ARE
ACTUALLY TOO SEVERE.
SO SHE'S ABSOLUTELY IN THE
MAINSTREAM IN THIS REGARD.
SO THERE'S NOTHING THAT'S
EXTRAORDINARY ABOUT IT AT ALL.
IF YOU TREAT HER OR TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THAT SHE'S LIKE ALL
OTHER FEDERAL JUDGES, THIS
SHOULD NOT BE AN ISSUE AT ALL.
IT SHOULD NOT BE OF CONCERN AT
ALL.
>> AS WELL, OBVIOUSLY --
>> SORRY, EXCUSE ME.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> IT WASN'T OF CONCERN, YOU
KNOW, IT WASN'T OF CONCERN WHEN
SHE WAS JUST CONFIRMED LESS THAN
A YEAR AGO.
A YEAR AGO IN JUNE 2021 AND
THREE REPUBLICAN SENATORS VOTED
IN HER FAVOR.
THERE'S NOTHING THAT'S DIFFERENT
ABOUT JUDGE JACKSON NOW THAN
THERE WAS IN JUNE 2021 WHEN THEY
KNEW SHE WAS A TOP CONTENDER FOR
THE SUPREME COURT.
AND IF THIS WAS A REASON TO NOT
CONFIRM HER, SHE SHOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN CONFIRMED ON THE DC
CIRCUIT.
SO ALL OF THOSE SENATORS WHO
VOTED FOR HER THEN SHOULD ALSO
BE VOTING FOR HER NOW.
>> ANGELA, I REMEMBER SPEAKING
TO YOU A FEW MONTHS AGO BEFORE
KETANJI BROWN JACKSON WAS
NOMINATED AND THERE WERE
REPUBLICANS THAT CAME OUT AND
OPPOSED THE NOMINATION OF A
BLACK WOMAN TO THE SUPREME COURT
JUST BY VIRTUE OF THEM BEING A
BLACK WOMAN.
THERE WERE INSINUATIONS ABOUT
QUALIFICATIONS, ET CETERA, AND
I'M WONDERING IF YOU THINK SHE'S
GOING TO BE ASKING SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT RACE AND WHETHER THAT
INFORMS HER JUDICIAL PHILOSOPHY?
>> I THINK SHE'LL BE ASKED THAT
QUESTION AS WELL.
IN FACT, IT'S A TROPE THAT'S
BEEN POSED TO MANY, MANY BLACK
JUDGES, MANY, MANY BLACK WOMEN
JUDGES.
SHE'LL BE ASKED THAT QUESTION.
WE SAW JUSTICE SOTOMAYOR FACE
SIMILAR QUESTIONS, INCLUDING
ABOUT THE COMMENTS THAT SHE MADE
WHEN SHE GAVE A SPEECH AT
BERKELEY ABOUT BEING A LATINA ON
THE BENCH AND JUDGE KETANJI
BROWN JACKSON WILL GET SIMILAR
TYPES OF QUESTIONS.
BUT I THINK PEOPLE SHOULD
RECOGNIZE THE THING CONSTANCE
MOTLEY SAID WHEN SHE WAS ASKED
TO RECUSE HERSELF FROM A
DISCRIMINATION CASE, ALL OF US
HAVE A RACE AND GENDER.
ALL OF US HAVE VARIOUS IDENTITY
CHARACTERISTICS, ALL OF US ARE
AFFECTED BY THOSE THINGS.
AND IF YOU'RE ASKING THOSE
THINGS FROM THE JUDGES OF COLOR
ONLY OR THE WOMEN OF COLOR ONLY
AND YOU'RE NOT ASKING THOSE OF
THE WHITE CANDIDATES, THAT IS
BASICALLY DISPARATE TREATMENT,
YOU'RE TREATING THEM VERY
DIFFERENTLY FROM WHITE
CANDIDATES FOR THE SUPREME
COURT.
AND YOU'RE ASSUMING THE ONLY
PEOPLE WHO CAN BE OBJECTIVE AND
FAIR AND IMPARTIAL ARE THOSE WHO
ARE WHITE.
>> ANGELA, YOU PROBABLY KNOW
BETTER THAN ANYBODY ELSE HERE
THAT, YOU KNOW, BLACK WOMEN ARE
VERY UNDERREPRESENTED ON THE
FEDERAL BENCH.
SO WHAT DOES THIS MOMENT, THIS
NOMINEE MEAN FOR YOU, BUT ALSO
FOR BLACK WOMEN IN LAW IN
GENERAL?
>> IT MEANS THE WORLD.
IT'S A MOMENT OF JOY.
IT IS AN IMPORTANT, HISTORICAL
MOMENT.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT,
AND WE'VE SEEN SOME OF THE
REASONS WHY IT'S IMPORTANT.
WE REALLY NEED TO DISRUPT THIS
NOTION OF WHAT A SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE LOOKS LIKE.
AND I THINK PART OF THE REACTION
TO JUDGE JACKSON'S NOMINATION IS
THAT PEOPLE HAVE AN IMAGE OF
WHAT A SUPREME COURT JUSTICE
LOOKS LIKE, AND BECAUSE A BLACK
WOMAN HAS NEVER BEEN A JUSTICE
IT'S HARD FOR SOME PEOPLE TO
EVEN IMAGINE IT.
AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT, I
THINK, FOR LITTLE BLACK GIRLS TO
BE ABLE TO LOOK UP AT THE
SUPREME COURT AND LIKE JUSTICE
GINSBURG, SAID IT'S NATURAL AND
PROPER FOR THEM TO BE SITTING ON
THE HIGHEST COURT OF THE LAND.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR ALL OF US,
WHITE BOYS, WHITE GIRLS, ASIAN
BOYS AND GIRLS, FOR EVERYONE TO
SEE THAT A BLACK WOMAN IS
NATURAL AND PROPER ON THE
SUPREME COURT.
WE HAVE TO DISRUPT THIS NOTION
ABOUT WHAT A JUDGE OR WHAT A
JUSTICE LOOKS LIKE.
>> SHE'S YET TO